[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin s'est
Hervé Marseille bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous à Marseille ré élu
dimanche sénateur des Hauts-de-Seine et
lui hier à la tête du groupe Union
centriste et toujours président de l'UDI
merci d'être avec nous on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour Oriane bonjour on va commencer
en parlant des sénatoriales Hervé
Marseille puisqu'on disait vous avez été
réélu hier à la tête du groupe Union
centrisme qui compte combien de
sénateurs
autant que nous en avions avant les
élections ce qui est déjà bien
on va en gagner
des mystères
d'ici la semaine prochaine voilà vous
devez le savoir non parce qu'il y a des
gens qui sont encore hésitants à l'heure
actuelle vous en avez combien vous avez
fait votre première réunion actuelle
combien on avait 57 membres on est
normalement à 56 57 là
désespéré
deux ou trois de plus donc en dessous
des 60 pour le moment pour le moment
vous allez gagner deux ou trois
sénateurs les républicains risquent d'en
perdre est-ce que ça rééquilibre la
majorité sénatoriale est-ce que vous
souhaitez plus peser écoutez d'abord il
y a une majorité sénatoriale
et
à l'évidence au sein de la majorité et
un équilibre et
on va réélire le président du Sénat
qui est la clé de voûte de notre
institution et puis on va continuer à
travailler en partenariat au sein de de
la majorité sénatoriale rééquilibrée
juste à la présidence du Sénat il y aura
candide à unique de la majorité
sénatoriale nous avons reçu hier le
président Larcher et
les conditions dans lesquelles nous
travaillons avec lui
son respect de la diversité font que bah
voilà il sera le candidat de la majorité
est-ce que vous restez clairement dans
la majorité sénatoriale les républicains
se disant dans l'opposition au
gouvernement ou est-ce que vous avez
envie vous de vous rapprocher du
gouvernement dont nous sommes dans
l'opposition et dans la majorité
sénatoriale mais
on a le droit de pas être obtus on a une
action depuis déjà bien des années
qu'on va qualifier
comme on le disait dans 2017 ça paraît
déjà tellement loin de constructive on
cherche des solutions au texte et c'est
pour ça qu'il y a des textes qu'on
adopte et des textes qu'on critiques
mais c'est opposition constructive comme
dirait Larcher vous vous dites que vous
êtes dans l'opposition gouvernement
beaucoup de des membres de mon groupe se
situe dans l'opposition donc simplement
encore une fois c'est pas c'est pas une
ligne rouge définitive
est-ce que vous connaissez votre petit
surnom chez les macronistes non
on si jamais vraiment pourquoi il va
voter mais dont le vote est essentiel on
peut faire basculer les choses de quoi
il parle ça vous plaît comment ça vous
plaît
bon il y a tellement de surnom et je me
garderai bien de dans l'exprimeriez en
tous les cas le rôle de votre groupe non
mais on est au Sénat je veux dire il y a
une majorité elle est diverses il y a
des sujets sur lesquels on peut être
d'accord avec les républicains
et il y a des sujets sur lesquels on
peut diverger on a des différences c'est
normal
des faire en tous les cas les majorités
sur sur des textes on trouve des
compromis il s'agit pas de faire ou
défaire on peut trouver des compromis
aussi vous êtes très courtisés
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement beaucoup
plus qu'avant non
sur l'immigration votre groupe va être
justement décisif non mais
le dossier de l'immigration à ma
connaissance va être examinée en
novembre la date et est fixée
forcément il faudra que la Conférence
des Présidents simplement d'ici là il va
y avoir beaucoup de de navets de
dialogue avec le gouvernement avec les
groupes et moi ce que j'espère c'est
qu'on trouve un compromis le
gouvernement justement espère que les
élections sénatoriales passées la
position des LR s'assouplisse un peu
c'est aussi ce que vous espérez
je crois que le Président de la
République dans son allocution de
dimanche soir a fait ce qu'on appelle un
budget déjà sur le dossier de
l'immigration il est allé
vers ceux qui critiquent le texte donc
je pense qu'on doit être très
hypocrisie sur la question des métiers
en tension oui d'accord il vaut mieux
bouger que pas de bouger donc pour qu'on
comprenne bien les républicains ici au
Sénat ils font de la régularisation en
tout cas des titres de séjour dans les
métiers en sont une ligne rouge j'ai dit
on ne votera pas le texte si cette
mesure figure dans le texte vous vous
êtes plutôt favorable à cette mesure
est-ce que vous allez trouver un
compromis dans la majorité sénatorielle
ou est-ce que vous partez divisé d'abord
je vous rappelle quand même que le texte
tel qu'il a été examiné par la
commission des lois a donné lieu à un
vote de 90% du texte donc on est en
train de parler d'un article ainsi pour
le gouvernement est essentiel
c'est le genre d'article qui pouvait de
toute façon déjà faire l'objet de
l'avoir réglementaire on n'était pas
obligé de faire un article etc
sortir du texte
ou faire un texte court qui renvoie à
une circulaire aujourd'hui c'est quoi la
régule la régule la circulaire Valls
c'est déjà du règlementaire bon on veut
afficher alors il y a ceux qui disent ah
non pas ça et ceux qui disent pourquoi
pas donc le problème c'est de savoir
s'il faut ou pas un article 3 un titre
particulier bon moi je pense qu'on doit
pouvoir regarder la solution de de la
voie circulaire pourquoi c'était déjà ce
qu'on évoquait quand on l'a travaillé en
commission des lois
j'en ai parlé un peu hier avec Bruno
retaillod mais
est-ce que pour lui aussi c'est le bon
compromis on est encore dans le dialogue
parce qu'il faut voir aussi avec
l'Assemblée nationale bon et puis il
disait pas de saucissonnage on veut pas
plusieurs textes oui bon est-ce que là
si vous sortez cette mesure et que vous
la passez par circulaire Bruno
Retailleau vous a dit que
vous savez il faut regarder plus
précisément ce qui est écrit bon on peut
pas juger ça en quelques mots mais je
moi je suis optimiste et je pense qu'on
doit pouvoir trouver une solution qui
est imaginée par la majorité aujourd'hui
qui est de retirer le texte que vous
avez vous étudié au Sénat et dans
présenter deux différents l'un sur les
régularisations dans les secteurs en
tension un autre sur les expulsions ça
va pas marcher je suis pas sûr
il y a une politique voilà on la
saucissonne pas en plusieurs textes vous
avez le sentiment qu'il a pas bougé là
dessus donc
on va parler d'un autre sujet on va
parler du pouvoir d'achat Elisabeth
borne a rencontré hier les distributeurs
de carburant pour leur demander de
vendre à prix coûtant ce qu'ils ont
accepté 120000 opérations dans 4000
stations jusqu'à la fin de l'année
est-ce que pour vous c'est suffisant
est-ce qu'il faut aller encore plus loin
moi je suis un peu épaté quand même par
ces histoires d'essence parce que
d'abord c'est un peu une injonction
contradictoire c'est ce qu'on fait une
planification écologique et on dit qu'il
faut sortir du moteur thermique et il
faut décarboner et puis l'autre côté on
s'est vertu à faire en sorte que les
gens consomment toujours plus d'essence
alors je comprends bien l'intérêt
politique les territoires faire
attention les gilets jaunes bon vous
trouvez que le gouvernement manque de
courage sur ce sujet-là
on est en train de faire deux choses en
même temps d'un côté on dit il faut des
carboner on fait le planification
à grands forts de publicité tam-tam et
de l'autre côté on dit il faut que
l'essence soit pas trop cher bon déjà
premier point c'est un peu surprenant ce
bon point
tout ça coûte quand même assez cher au
budget de l'État parce que je veux dire
les aides qu'on prévoit pour un certain
nombre de familles formidable on n'est
pas contre mais ce que je veux dire tout
ça coûte très cher dans le même temps on
a 3000 milliards de dettes le ministre
de l'Économie nous dit on est à l'euro
près voilà et on a l'impression de Bercy
c'est le Qatar quoi je veux dire tous
les matins on fait des chèques on envoie
des aides etc
carburant de 200 euros promis par
Emmanuel Macron il fallait pas le faire
là aussi ça coûte 500 millions ok mais
simplement tout ça cette politique de
Stop and Go un coup on fait
l'essence
moins cher après on revient on dit non
on va faire l'essence
avec la planification écologique en
arrière-plan on y comprend plus rien
donc et vous le voterez ou pas ce chèque
de ce propos il faut aider il faut aider
les gens mais ce qu'on veut surtout si
vous avez le même maintenant que le
gouvernement il faut faire des économies
mais en même temps il faut aider les
gens non mais comme ça change tous les
jours à un moment donné le jour où il
faut voter vous vous retrouvez face à un
texte où on vous dit est-ce qu'il faut
aider les gens qui en ont le plus besoin
ou pas la réponse est oui mais en même
temps tout ça manque de cohérence enfin
c'est c'est pas très sérieux et moi je
préférerais quand même ce qu'on demande
depuis l'an dernier on n'a pas été suivi
mais j'entends une petite musique on y
revient c'est que plutôt que de demander
poliment au patron de Total ou de tel
autre distributeur s'il vous plaît
monsieur à votre bon cœur est-ce qu'on
peut faire un geste c'est que l'État
soit moi je suis républicain c'est
régulateur c'est à dire que on taxe
les profits
insensés et exceptionnel que font
certaines grandes entreprises et des
tarot distribues c'est ça le rôle de
l'État plutôt que de bidouiller avec des
opérateurs et s'il te plaît est-ce que
tu peux faire l'essence moins cher donc
on va demander cette action
et vous souhaitez qu'elle revienne dans
le débat au moins
il y a des profits exceptionnels donc
une taxation exceptionnelle et l'État
redistribue plutôt que de un jour de
dire est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire
l'essence moins cher total nous dit 1,99
subtils et puis de l'autre côté
les opérateurs qui disent bon finalement
à prix coûtant pourquoi pas mais à un
moment ou un autre ils vont se rattraper
vous connaissez vous beaucoup de
commerçants qui acceptent de ne pas
gagner de l'argent
de la taxe sur les super profits pendant
l'examen budgétaire vous allez revenir
là dessus
Bruno Le Maire justement qui présente ce
matin le budget en conseil des mini 16
milliards d'économies puisque vous
demandiez au gouvernement de faire des
écoles ça veut dire que vous allez le
voter c'est pas c'est pas assez c'est
pas assez
je veux dire les courbes qui sont celles
du gouvernement la loi de programmation
dont on parle déjà depuis bien des mois
puisqu'on avait rejeté déjà au mois de
décembre
cette loi de programmation elle ne va
pas assez loin la charge de la dette
elle devient monstrueuse avec la hausse
des taux d'intérêt donc il faut agir
alors la différence que nous avons avec
nos partenaires républicains c'est que
ils veulent des économies mais que nous
on veut une part d'économie mais aussi
un levier fiscal c'est-à-dire un certain
nombre de mesures qui permettent de
retrouver des marges de recettes parce
qu'il suffit pas non plus
oui d'une certaine façon sur certaines
tranches l'indexation l'indexation des
barèmes par exemple avec l'inflation
vous pouvez ne pas toucher aux barèmes
les plus hauts ce qui correspond à une
forme de hausse
vous pouvez toucher à la flat taxe là
aussi sur les les revenus du capitaux
tirés des ventes d’actions etc vous
pouvez donc la philosophie du
gouvernement qui est de ne pas augmenter
les impôts vous dites c'est une erreur
politique non c'est pas une erreur
politique c'est simplement il faut la
compléter par un levier fiscal
mais il faut les cibler c'est pas
les impôts dans tous les sens c'est
ciblé on voit très bien qu'il y a des
niches fiscales qui méritent d'être
considéré on voit bien qu'il y a des la
flattag sur les rachats d'actions
d'ailleurs le président de la République
en avait parlé dans une intervention il
y a quelques mois et puis ça a pas été
suivi des faits
il y a là des moyens de trouver de
l'argent vous pensez obtenir avoir
obtenir des gages sur ce sur ce texte là
vous pensez que le gouvernement va être
obligé de passer par un 49-3 pour le
faire voter au Sénat
à l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée je pense
qu'il a prévu de ne pas éterniser les
discussions en faisant un 49-3 d'autant
que le Front national le rassemblement
national maintenant a décidé de
s'abstenir et que pour montrer que
ce sont abstenus aussi en commission
[Musique]
on est habitué à des choses un peu
baroques à l'Assemblée nationale donc je
pense que le gouvernement
qui ne lit pas dans le marc de café se
dit que si on veut terminer vite fait
bien fait l'affaire il faut un 49,3 ce
qui permet de s'assoudre de la position
du rassemblement national
mais quand les discussions vont arriver
au Sénat ça va être compliqué aussi
d'après ce que vous dites
de toute façon les discussions sont
toujours compliquées sur le sur le
budget ça n'est pas simple et donc oui
on va avoir des discussions
certainementologie vous employez les
mêmes mots à l'Assemblée nationale
tout est possible je veux dire
la discussion du du budget à l'Assemblée
c'est un peu pour les plus anciens le
rallye androse quoi c'est la conduite
sur glace je veux dire vous savez pas
trop
si vous arrivez au bout
une sortie de route est toujours
possible
il peut y avoir un moment donné une
conjonction qui fait que une motion de
censure est votée bon pour l'instant
comment non je le souhaite pas que vous
dites 16 milliards c'est pas assez pour
vous il faudrait qu'il y ait combien
d'économies dans ce budget
d'abord la courbe prévue par le
gouvernement elle est pas elle est pas
très réaliste d'ailleurs le Haut Conseil
pour les finances publiques le souligne
il parle de budget peu réaliste donc la
courbe elle est assez peu réaliste en
plus on a des sujets par exemple comme
le
planification écologique on voit pas
tellement où sont les recettes on voit
bien la planification ce qu'elle impose
et par exemple en matière de logement où
il y a un gros sujet et où il va falloir
faire quelque chose donc je pense que il
faut regarder plus finement c'est pas
tellement en volume 16 ça paraît
beaucoup mais c'est surtout de l'aspect
réaliste les recettes les plus sûrs
un autre texte oui qui est assez
compliqué qui est discuté en ce moment à
l'Assemblée le texte sur le plein emploi
qui contient un volet sur le RSA au
Sénat le RSA avait été conditionné le
scénario avait voulu que le RSA soit
conditionné à des heures d'activité
l'Assemblée nationale vient de lever ce
conditionnement obligatoire en tous les
cas qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
c'est dommage parce que
déjà on a recréé ce qui paraissait
surprenant d'ailleurs que ça n'existe
pas la la corrélation entre le RSA et
l'inscription à Pôle emploi parce que
c'était dissocié c'est comme ça ça fait
partie des choses bizarres de notre
système s'il suffit simplement de
s'inscrire à Pôle emploi pour pouvoir
bénéficier du RSA
ça suffit pas bah non on voit bien qu'il
y a un tas d'endroits où on parlait tout
à l'heure de métiers en tension on a des
des possibilités d'emploi il faut faire
l'effort de sur la formation et
davantage trouver les comment dire les
cohés les corrélations et la cohérence
entre les demandeurs d'emploi et les
possibilités d'emploi c'est un vieux
sujet mais je crois que c'est pas
anormal c'est ce qu'avait dit le Sénat
qu'on demande aux gens un minimum de
contribution
contrepartie de l'effort collectif qui
est fait donc il va y avoir un problème
avec la version votée par l'Assemblée
nationale si elle l'est en l'état c'est
habituel
on n'est pas nécessairement d'accord
avec les députés donc on reverra ça ici
un mot sur la fin de vie puisque le
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
a dit que finalement le projet de loi ne
serait pas examiné avant l'année
prochaine au Parlement est-ce que vous
pensez qui est vera le jour et est-ce
que vous le souhaitez
écoutez le débat est important
moi personnellement je suis hostile
ce qui est un Asie suicide assisté parce
que quand on parle de la fin de vie
c'est très complexe c'est un problème
intime ça fait partie de ces sujets où
chaque parlementaire doit pouvoir
exercer son libre arbitre peut pas avoir
des lignes collectives sur des sujets
comme celui-là il faut bien une
évolution de la loi je trouve que la loi
Léonetti est une loi suffisante il faut
peut-être juste un peu la compléter j'en
ai Leonetti qui est un ami avec lequel
j'en ai parlé et hostile à l'évolution
également
il faut bien expliquer à nos concitoyens
ce que c'est je veux dire parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de différences entre le
suicide assisté le l'euthanasie et
d'autres formes j'allais dire de fin de
vie ça n'est pas simple on peut pas on
peut pas
j'entends parler de référendum il faut
c'est compliqué parce que simplifier en
quelques mots répondent oui non à un
sujet comme cela ça me paraît quand même
extrêmement risqué donc moi je suis pour
qu'il y a un débat
et un débat qui aille au fond des choses
Christelle une question sur les autres
revenir un petit peu sur en arrière le
président avait promis de tirer les
leçons des émeutes qui ont eu lieu au
mois de juin et juillet début septembre
il a toujours pas parlé visiblement peu
de groupes de travail autour de ce sujet
ça vous inquiète un peu
oui parce que c'est un sujet qui est
pendant depuis des déjà plusieurs années
Jean-Louis Borloo avait fait beaucoup
dans ce domaine chacun s'en souvient il
avait fait un rapport qui a été écarté
de façon un peu humiliante même et je
pense qu'il faut revenir à ce qui avait
fait la philosophie de ce qui a été la
philosophie de Jean-Louis Borloo sur le
sujet parce que il y a certainement
plusieurs de nombreuses causes
vous vous avez pas été consulté vous
laisseznateurs sur des solutions
envisagées les causes vos analyses et on
en a parlé avec le président de la
République quand il y a eu cette réunion
le 30 août à Saint-Denis bon on voit
bien que il y a l'école il y a
l'éducation il y a des problèmes
d'autorité il y a le problème du
logement du peuplement
là maintenant parce que le délai fixé
c'est il y a deux semaines déjà
et donc
simplement d'abord très sincèrement
j'étais un peu occupé
et puis
dans la semaine oui il y avait une
cohérence aussi à travailler ici au
Sénat avec tous ceux et tous celles qui
avaient travaillé au groupe de travail
sur la sur les territoires on peut pas
écrire une chose
d'un côté alors qu'on a travaillé en
collectif bon il y a un problème par
exemple sur le logement c'est qu'on
redonne aux élus la main au moins en
partie sur ce qu'on appelle pudiquement
le peuplement c'est à dire sur la
capacité attribuer les logements et
aménager la ville est-ce que vous
craignez qu'il y a une tentation de la
part de l'Élysée de tourner la page sans
en tirer réellement des leçons est-ce
que vous sentez ça il y a un risque que
l'actualité chasse l'actualité que on
passe à autre chose assez rapidement
parce qu'il y a un tas d'autres sujets
on vient de parler de de beaucoup de
problèmes qui essayent le pays et les
Français donc
je pense que dommage parce que c'est un
problème permanent nos banlieues ça
concerne essentiellement nos banlieue
mais de plus en plus les banlieues
partout en France pas seulement en
région parisienne ou dans les grandes
villes on l'a vu au mois de juillet
quand il y a eu ses émeutes un dernier
un dernier mois avait Marcel puisque
vous êtes également président de l'UDI
on l'a dit est-ce qu'il y aura une liste
udi aux élections européennes
pour l'instant on n'est pas du tout dans
ce sujet
on va en parler et on verra en début de
l'année prochaine quels sont les options
qui qui s'offrent à nous parce que moi
je ne sais pas pour l'instant qu'elle
quels sont les orientations des uns et
des autres donc on va d'abord passer
parce qu'il y a un cand
IdaT
[Musique]
les européennes c'est formidable
et c'est évidemment important mais
l'organisation de notre vie publique
on sait très bien que s'il y a plusieurs
candidats du centre droit
européenne d'ici 2027 d'ici 2027 il y a
de fortes chances pour qu'on se retrouve
donc il faut s'unir
des Manon et les européennes sont la
première guerre de l'Union je dis
simplement que il faut y réfléchir dès
maintenant vous viendrez nous en parler
quand vous avez pris votre décision à
votre disposition merci Hervé Marseille
d'avoir été notre invité Christelle on
regarde la Une de La Dépêche c'est
l'inflation cette France qui craque
c'est à la Une de nombreux témoignages
passionnants c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Christelle merci
au club des territoires